Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Grave
An Indie Horror game that promises dynamic environment spawning
and if dynamic environment spawning means procedurally generated
then I am very interested in this horror game
One thing I did notice as soon as I loaded up ,
that even though this is a desert of death and destruction, this looks awfully nice !
There´s a lot of detail put into this and I´ve been pretty lucky
because this week I´ve been able to play some actually high quality indie horror games
which there´s been a rather um... drought of
there´s been a lack of really high quality ones so I am eager to give this one a try
This ... kinda .... want ..
Oh was I su....
Was that me or was that a breathy breathy over here ?!
Someone want to say...
OHH!!! OHH!!! OHH!!!
Is that a thing?!
Oh, I think that's a thing!
Hey! Oh. Hi!
Okay I'll move on.
You a breath on...
Okay?! Hi!
Oh, it's a T.V
Some little girl gonna pour out of that T.V
And talk to me about rings and such?
I'm not ready for marriage!
You get out of here!
Oh...
Woah...
Cool!
I can throw it!
Hahaha
Oh they didn't even show what happened.
Hey buddy.
Uhh...
You okay?
You okay in there?
Alright I'll move on
How many matches do I have?
The counter in the bottom says
one matches, zero.
So I guess I'm winning against the matches?!
Oh.. What?!
That was not there before!
What the hell!
What is..?
okay... okay... The LSD is kicking in!
I'm losing my mind!
I'm falling into... Oh.. Oh...
You still breathing in there?!
You all right?! You need match?!
I got matches! Can I jump?
That's the sissiest jump...
Look I'm jumping like two inches off the ground.
What in the... Ugh
I swear I'm stronger than...
Hey buddy! You want some matches?!
Maybe they might help with your breathing problem!
Ahh! You are pretty good.
Okay...
I guess I have an unlimited matches now.
Or maybe I just got a giant box of a thousand matches.
So either way I'm gonna to follow these rail road tracks.
Into this umm... mine looking thingy.
I don't know if this all randomly generated
or if this is just kind of the lay out here.
I didn't read the instructions very well.
That's a pretty common th...
Oh... It got dark real quick.
It got dark real quick!
That's a pretty common theme with me
Because I am... Dumb... I am the dumb...
And I don't read instructions
When they are given to me
Oh
Wow! Cool!
So I actually have some light in here.
I wonder how long till they turn off.
Because that's a pretty common theme in these...
Horror games.
God! That is pretty!
This is made on the unity engine by the way.
But I don't recall unity engine looking
quiet like this.
This is very nice.
I like the ominous glow of red of my match of the walls
It's delightful!
Okay.
Anyways! Enough harping of the game itself
Ohh! I called!
No!
You think you can mess with me?!
I've screamed in the face of thousands of horror monsters.
You think you are worthy.
Ok nevermind...
Best not to taunt the monster before I meet him
Cause I'm sure that there is one in here!
This would be a great lay out.
Like I love! I don't know if this is pesidrually generated
because it didn't say it was
It just said it was a dynamic environment spawning
But... I do love it
Because SCP Concainment Breach uch...
Containment Breach
Is one of my favorite games
There's more matches right?
I already have matches!
Can I throw myself to my death?
I can't even jump over that ledge!
I'm that wimpy
I'm like a body builder that only focused
On upper body strength
So I got like gigantic titanic muscles
But on my legs are just little twigs
Oo... hueh!
Oh cool Ok, that's useful.
Oh, what was that?
WOAH!
Oh ok.
I need not be freaked out about that
That was just a little hole, in the ceiling there...
Hueh!
Bueh!
Hueh
Anybody there? Ok.
Hup!
Who's there?
Somebody wanna MESS WITH ME?
I'VE GOT MATCHES!
Ha, I didn't think so...
[Ominous sounds in the background]
SHUT UP! I heard that!
You stomping around in that mud over there
Building sandcastles.
Oh right.
Oh ain't that delightful?
Aren't railroad tracks supposed to go somewhere?
Is this Wryly Coyote where he painted a...
Wryly and a... Never mind
People probably don't even know who Wryly Coyote is anymore
Oh right then.
Is there a monster up there?
Is it gonna get me?
You're gonna get some matches up the butt! Ok Fine.
Haven't seen anything yet
So I'm assuming they're waiting on it
Till I get to... Where I'm supposed to... What is it?
Ok what is that?
Hueh! What is that?
Hueh! What is it?
I'm probably scarier than anything in this c...
Did I just...
Did I just shatter my leg?
One of my twig legs just broke in half
And I kinda am limping now?
What is that?
These broken pillar thingys
Why
Why is going on
I don't like the smell of this
I don't like the claustrophobia of this
Hueh! Anything?
Oh... OH!!!
Well...
Oh ok, I was expecting that I was gonna be in the cave for a while
Unless this is just a red herring and I'm not really...
Outta the caves yet.
Which way was I supposed to go? Was that my first choice?
What is that?
Oh it's a power line
I keep going what is that and there's perfectly logical... answers
Okey Dokey
So what what whawa, what is happening?
Why is there a shadow?
NO!
NO DON'T BEAT ME SHADOW!
I'm going!
I'm running as fast as I CAN!
THE SHADOW'S KEEPING UP WITH ME!
Is that a bad thing or is the sun just going down?
I have no idea!
What is that?
What is this thing? It's a C with a...
STOP IT!
YOU STOP THAT!
I... I don't know what's going on so you...
I'm sorry
It looks like the belly button piercing on a...
Very big lady
If ya know what I mean
Ok, that shadow stopped creeping
And now I'm going up to another tusky...
Ah, tusty
OOH THAT IS SO PRETTY!
Ok
Sorry, I got freaked out for a second.
I get... Uh you know
My expectation on these horror games are very low
When I play them
So when they're delightful and look fantastic
I like...
I like really like them!
This is awesome!
I really like it!
And the environment is cool to like...
The dust ball is not a common theme in any horror game
That I've played before
Maybe wa... What is that?
Is that a can of gasoline
So I can burn this barn down to the ground?
They shouldn't have give me this
What...
WHA...ARE THEY SERIOUS?!?!
ARE THEY S... I CAN BURN THINGS!
aw...
Aw wuh...
Well that not uh.
Aw come on!
I was really hoping for something there
Maybe if I soak the... Hya!
No?
AWWW!!
You can't just give me gasoline...
And not give me the option to burn everything I see!
I'M LIKE A PYROMANIAC NOW!
You...
Why did it get dark all of a sudden?
Where's the power?
Okey dokey
Those matches do not last long
On the ground they do not last long
But in my hand I can apparently hold them forever witho...
Okay...
Well that's out of place
One of these things, is not like the other
One of these things just doesn't belong
Oh a flashlight!
Ooh ok, that somehow made it much worse
I suddenly got all these Vietnam flashbacks...
About uh... Slender Man
Oh you're a...
Oh, you're a thing!
You're actuallly a thing?
Why are you a thing?
AH!
Can I burn you alive?
Ha!
Ra!
Rah!
Oooh, it's not doing much!
What do I do?
Do I get the gas can?
Uh uh!
Where'd you go?
You're still there!
Errr, burn burn burn baby!
Burn it up!
AHHH!
It didn't burn fast enough!
What is going on?
How do I beat you?
Uh... Maybe I climb up into the barn!
I'm very... Uh... Frazzled right now because I'm...
I'm uh... I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm at a lost for what to do!
Just give me a second
Wait, maybe if I lead him over the fire I created there.
Come on buddy
You know you want to step into the flames
Where'd you go?
Huh?
Where'd you go buddy?
Whaaaaa what keeps...
Why is he doing that?
[High Pitched Scream]
AHHBLEBLUBLE
You shut the f up!
I'll burn you alive!
[Mark Imitating Pouring Sound]
Light!
Come on!
FIRE!!
BURN!
AH YOU DIDN'T BURN!
[Some Sort Of Scream]
[Monstrous Screech]
Is he eating my butt?
Was he eating my butt?
Whaaat?
Ooh, C for checkpoint.
It saved my soul
Welp, that was the first death let's get back into it
[Some gibberish]
Really I was doing it wrong
A he he he he
Was I getting dabidged?
Was I getting dablidged?
I don't recall anything hitting me
But I seem to have lost health
I wasn't watching my health metre down there
Okey dokey
Wha, Oh!
Wha, whe where is da gahh
Where is the gaaasoline?
I don't know if the gasoline really helped me but...
I want it
Well there's the flashlight
Ok
Things aren't bad yet
What is that?
Huh?
Batteries!
Ooh, it's one of those big battery flashlights
The one with the very gearthy uh... thingy on it
Ooh!
Oh ok, I thought there was like a body up there
I got a flare
I got two more flares
Nobody wants to mess with me
BING BONG!
BRING IT ON!
Ok, apparently not
Apparently that's not a thing I can do
But if someone wants to mess with me they're going to be awfully...
Chuffed
Chuffed!
I think chuffed is the British word for exited
What is that word?
Everything in Britain it's so weird
Chuffed
I'm awfully chuffed to see this scenario
I'm going to go see what this big glowy thing was
No I need to find the gas first
Dammit, where'd the gas go?
The thing probably not gonna trigger until I find the gas
Where'd it go?
Where did it go!
This is a load of ah, a load of bull!
Give me my gas!
I want gas
Anybody?
Seriously?
Where the hell do I go to find it?
Shut up!
I'm going to go out and see what that thing is
If I can't find the gas out there then I'm just...
S... Squat out of luck
What the hell are you?
And why are you shaking the ground?
Good Lordy Loo!
You are massive!
You're like one of the...
Wha, a flash bang?
A flash bang?
I seem to be getting the idea that these things
Don't like light but what is this thing?
Holy hell that's awesome!
It's like one of those gates
Er a ba ba ba ba bababba
[Weird Sound]
It's one of those things from Mass Effect
You know what I'm talking about
Oh it got dark
Ok, I guess it's time for the monsters to come out and play
Don't worry, I've got a flash bang with your name on it
Sunny Jim
You wanna tussle?
With my ma...
What is that?
Who are you?
[Deep Breathing in Background]
No
No, I've got a flash bang!
You get banged!
What the hell did that do?
Ahh the most useless thing I've ever seen
AAAHHHH!
Why aren't I doing anything?
Oh, I don't think I was doing anything
Waa, stop breathing
Ooh, he's breathing all over me
I don't like it
I don't much care for it
What is that?
A lamp?
Ahh, ok
Why?
Wh... Why?
Why is this here?
Why?!?!
There's another flash bang that don't do jack
BUH BA BU BUH BA!
Why am I shooting my thing like a gun?
Where'd you go?
Where did he go?
Ooo, I guess I'll just take a break and watch some T...
AAH HA
Where'd you go?
I heard you breathing
Ahh there you are!
BLE BLE BLE BLE BLE
Am I shooting it?
Uh what? Why?
Well it ju ju ju
This doesn't make sense!
Eeh, I don't know
I don't know but that thing's going crazy over there
Where'd you go?
A BUH BA BU BUH BA
YA BA BA BA BA BA
Is this...
Is this actually doing anything?
This is NOT!
IT'S NOT DOING ANYTHING!
What about that thing?
Well I don't know what I'm supposed to do?
A BA BA BA BA
Wait it ooh...
Did that? No ok.
It was just already doing that.
A BE BE BE BE BE
[High Pitched Screech]
A BA BA BA
Ooh it is working!
It didn't work on that other guy though
Ahh, suck on that b...
What? Excuse me! Pardon me!
You get some!
Suck on my light, suck my light!
Yeah. Oh yeah, that's right!
Ooh, that's a pretty sky
Ok, so.
My chuffness levels are at maximum
My jimmies are unrazzled
God I just hear the breathing
Poof!
Okey dokey
That's good
Ah you stop there
Ah it's a double
It's a double whammy
I'm going to...
CHU CHA CHA!
Alrighty then
So what was up with the red guy?
Hey, don't you do that
Aw outta here instantaneously
Because the sun's coming up apparently
I turned on the generator
Or not because I don't have any gas
[Moment of Realization]
Was I supposed to pour gas in the generator...
And not on the ground like a moron?
Ha ha
I'm just an idiot that was like...
Burn!
BURN EVERYTHING ALIVE!
And I was supposed to put it into the thing
I'm... I'm an idiot
Ok so now what?
It's daylight now
And the sun...
I didn't actually know that the sun moved through the sky like that but...
Now what?
Seriously, now what?
I don't know
It's gotta be something to do with this
Oh great belly button ring of the Gods
Tell me what I must do!
And I shall probably do it...
Maybe...
I'm gonna head back
Because there's another way to go out the cave
And I can't really find anything else here
Uh oh!
UH OH!
I apparently done something wrong
What is going on?
Oh, goodness
What... WHAT?
No, I CAN'T LEAVE!!
NO LET ME LEAVE YOU BASTARD!
I wanna go home!
I WANNA GO HOME!
NOOO!
Ooh goodness
Welp, apparently I'm gonna be here a while
So I better get comfortable
Maybe there was some...
Ooh, that happened quickly
Where'd the forest go?
The forest disappeared!
THE FOREST VANISHED!!
I CAN'T BE ALRIGHT WITH THIS!!
Ok, alright
I'm not going crazy
The forest disappeared
The big thompy thomp over there
The belly button ring of the Gods is gone
Oh no you don't
Why is this not hurting you?
Boosh!
YA BA BA BA BAO!
I'm outta batteries after this
So I'm going to have to make do with whatever I have else
And I don't think I even have gas
It's that guy!
It's that red guy!
The one that isn't affected w...
A BA BA BA BA BA BA!
BA BA BA BA BA!
Die, die already!
Ok
So come on, bring it on
Ah there you are
Come on
A BA BA BA BA BA
I really am shooting this thing like a gun
It's almost hilarious if it wasnt ridiculous
Ok, ooh another flashlight
YA BA BA BA BA
That didn't do anything for me
I already have a flashlight
I don't need another one
What I do need...
Is more batteries!
Where can I get more batteries?
Or a gas can, that would be nice too
What am I doing?
Why am I doing...
Hey!
Hey you bitch, you wanna back up a tad?
Where... Where are you?
Show yourself!
I've got a flashlight, I'm armed and slightly
Slightly chuffed!
I'm slightly chuffed!
My chuffness levels you don't wanna mess with them
I got a flare now
Don't look at me, I'm serious business bro!
Oh that's a guy!
I don't want to mess with the guy!
I don't think I want to mess with the guy anyway
Because I don't think I can kill the guy
What do we do?
I'm gonna mess with the guy!
Cause I've got nothing better to do
Huh, there's more than one guy!
Ooh, you breathy
You weird
Stop being breathy and weird
Oh ok, that was a mistake
That was a bit of a mistake
What else do I have?
Flash bang?
I don't think a flash bang's gonna do much to them
Ugh...
[Screech]
Shut up
Shut up I've got a match!
Beh! Beh! Beh! Beh! Beh! Beh!
Uh oh, this is bad
What is that?
Oh that's my
ASJDNASDKL
It's the guy!
Ahh get away from me!
No thank you
Generator won't work
Oh I'm trapped
Ahh
Maximum chuffness engaged!
Oh wait there's a thing over there!
I see something over there!
No, is that the same place I'm just in?
Is that the same town?
I don't know
Hang on, wait, no, ok get my flash...
Shut up!
Shut ye mouth!
That is, that is, that is something else
That might be the same exact...
Is this just looping back and forth forever?
Oh no
Am I going to be trapped here for the rest of eternity?
No!
What?
Wait a minute, what?
Excuse me?
[Gasp]
OOHHHH!!
THAT WAS IT?
Aww, I wanted to play more
But ooh
Alright, so that was Grave
That was actually really cool
I misunderstood it's not proceduraly generated I think
But still...
It was very interesting
I liked it
Very detailed
Not to shabby if I had to say so
But the gun shooty flashlight mechanic
Was a little bit wonky
They could work on that one
But either way, great
If you wanna play it for yourself
There's a link in the description
Obviously the website's right there
If you wanna see more horror videos that I've done
Click the annotation over there
It's a giant playlist, like a 140 videos
For you to check out
And if you've got more suggestions for good
Horror games that you want me to play in the future
Let me know in the comments
Thanks again everybody for watching
And as always...
I will see you... In the next video
Buh Bye!!
[Outro Music]